welcome
everyone and thank you for joining us
for our presentation
titled using 3d in vitro
tumoroids for personalized medicine it
is my pleasure to introduce you to
marilyna
louisidu the deputy director of the
division of surgery and interventional
science of the head of the department of
surgical biotechnology
and the professor of cancer
nanotechnology
at university college london for a
complete biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the end
of her presentation please join me now
and welcoming
marilyna though easy do i will now turn
the presentation over to her welcome
elena
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to present our work on tumoroids
these are three-dimensional in vitro
models of cancer
and we used humoroids to assess disease
progression
response to drugs and also
we use tumoroids that we create
with patient-derived cells to create
a personalized oncology platform
cancer incidence is rising globally
and the term cancer is an umbrella term
that covers more than 200 diseases
one in three or even one in two of us
will get cancer
in a lifetime but most of these are
solid
cancers the lumps such as breast cancer
prostate cancer bowel cancer and lung
cancer
the treatment for solid cancers is
excision
by surgery however fifty percent of
these patients will need
extra treatment adjavant treatment to
further eradicate the disease
unfortunately
all these extra treatments such as
chemotherapy and radiotherapy
only have 30 percent success
which is a very sub optimal outcome
therefore there's a need for better
models
to determine better drugs
we decided to recapitulate
solid cancers in the laboratory
which we call tumoroids and these are
basically
synthetic 3d cancer mimics
and we believe that this is a
robust investigating tool to
assess disease progression evaluate
treatments
and optimize patient response and a
vision
really is to create a platform of tumors
which are created with cells from
each patient so we can predict
the response to treatment for each
patient
so in this talk what i'd like to do is
just describe the methodological
development of tumoroids
and then describe specifically how we
incorporated patient-derived cells into
tumoroids
and focus also on one particular step
which is the tissue dissociation
that results in cells from patient
tissues
and then i will just close with the way
forward
so methodological development of
tumeroids has been carried out
using mostly cell lines to be able to
optimize
each particular characteristic
we started off by wanting to mimic the
composition
of the solid cancer you can see
in the biopsy image on the top left
the cancer cells which are reddish brown
are trying to
organize themselves into glands
and they're embedded within stroma which
is connective tissue
which is populated by other non-cancer
cells such as
fibroblasts and endothelial cells
to recapitulate this we decided to
create humanoids
in by combining specific compartments
so a cancer mass which is encapsulated
in a stromal compartment and we create
these
using mostly collagen type 1 which is
the most
abundant protein in the body in the
connective tissue
but we also add one more element
we create dense tumoroids
because we're very aware that solid
cancers are dense
tissues and we feel that the
biomechanics of the tissue
also play a role
to make tumeroids we use the
raft system by lonza this
system basically is comprises
absorbers that we can put in different
wells
and they will take away fluid and create
a much stiffer 3d construct
the images at the bottom show the
process of creating complex tumors
on the top left you can see that we used
96 well plates where we mixed
collagen and cancer cells and then
we applied the rough absorbers
to expel the fluid
these rather stiff cancer masses then
get
put into twenty four well plates
which are already filled with the
stromal compartment components so that's
again
collagen one mixed with other cells and
you can see that in the middle
image in that image you can actually
see with the naked eye the difference
between the cancer must be already
created
and the gelatin hydrogel around it
which will create the stroma to further
compress
and expel fluid we apply bigger
absorbers
and we end up with what you see on the
on the bottom
right those are tumors in 24 well plates
and you can see there's a cancer mass
very clearly delineated
however it is embedded in the stroma
tuberoids are similar to cancer tissues
and i demonstrate this by the two images
of the paraffin embedded tumoroid
on the left that shows that cancer cells
are trying to create glands
in the cancer mass and you can see how
similar that is
to the cancer cells within the bowel
cancer
biopsy on the right
and that can also be demonstrated a
higher magnification
and the high magnification images are
embedded
within the red box the cancer tissue is
the top
image and tumor issues
are the middle and the bottom image and
one of them
is of a low metastatic potential and the
other one is a high metastatic potential
so the point here is to show that the
behavior of cancer cells morphologically
within a 3d tissue is very similar
within tumoroids
to those in cancer tissues themselves
so we went through a number of
reiterations of tumoroids
for a large number of different solid
cancers
and the final
more complex tumor rate we tend to use
nowadays
is demonstrated by this particular pair
of
images that show a colorectal tumoroid
inflorescence the
left hand image shows the cancer mass in
green and particularly cancer cells
in red that are moving away from the
cancer mass
into the stromal compartment now the
stromal compartment itself
in these images is populated by
endothelial cells
in green which have undergone
end-to-end fusion so they if you like
you could describe them as a primitive
vasculature
the stroma in this case is also
populated by fibroblasts but they're not
stained by a particular fluorescent
stain
and what i would like to draw your
attention to
is the image to the right
the image to the right again shows red
cancer cells
moving into the stroma invading into the
stroma
and the invasive edges
have lost their ck20
red staining you can only see them in
blue
and that's really very exciting for us
because
this is what we see in biopsies
from colorectal cancer tissues where
very invasive edges lose that particular
biomarker
so we're very happy that our tumoroids
mimic a lot of what we see in patient
tissues
now this type of reiteration of the
tumor
has got a number of modifications in it
for example we added extra proteins
within the stroma
such as laminin or collagen for
etc and they're the ones that actually
are needed for the um
endothelial cells to undergo this
morphological
change i'm not going to go through too
many details about the tumoroids
apart from to say that we have
interrogated
the way they invade and that by changing
different components of the tumoroid
or different stiffness and density
we can change the patterns of invasion
i will also say that we can change the
complexity
of these vascular networks and what we
actually found that what was really
really
interesting when we compared pairs of
cell lines that had a low metastatic
potential
versus a high metastatic potential
regardless of the cancer type
we seem to get trends of
how cells behave in tumoroids
so particularly for vascular networks
the complexity is reduced
when the cancer cells are of high
metastatic potential
and also the invasion the rage of
invasion the surface area of invasion
is increased in high metastatic
potential tumeroids than low metastatic
potential
tumoroids and we've also
incorporated cancer associated
fibroblasts in tumoroids
from patients with that particular
specific cancer type so
we have noticed that the presence of
calves
cancer assorted fibroblasts
really really promotes invasion and
that's actually
expected last slide i would like to talk
about
is just a demonstration how we use
tumoroids
to show response to
drugs and this particular slide
has a panel of images that show
at the top the
cancer mass itself
the second row of images shows the
junction between the cancer mass
and the connective stroma
and the third row of images shows what
happens
in the stroma itself so
this particular experiment was using
kidney tumoroids
interrogated for response with pazopanib
which is a drug currently used in the
clinic
now pazopanib is supposed to be an
anti-angiogenic
drug but by using the tumeric platform
we could see how pazopanib
exerted its effects both within
the cancer mass the cancer invasion
and the stroma itself so
if i may just bring to your attention
the images
again you can see on the top panel
that the treated
tumoroids are
distressed compared to
the left-hand side image of the control
humanoids the second panel
shows that the invasion
from the cancer cell into cancer mass
into the
stroma is reduced in the treated
tumoroids compared to the untreated ones
and the third panel
shows that there is catastrophic events
in the stroma of the treated tumoroids
compare to the untreated tumoroids
in that particular panel in the
untreated tumorous
you can see cells in red cells in
green sends cells in um
there's probably one more color but you
can see
when you compare with a stroma of the
triggered humoroids
that the whole vascular network has been
destroyed and that's expected with
pazopanib
i'm now going to go on and describe our
attempts
at using patient-derived cells
to create tumors
the ray determining step of
creating a platform with patient-derived
cells
is to actually have quite a high
standard
of success for isolating and growing
patient-derived cells
so we spent about two and a half years
with a minimum of 24 samples
from tissues of patients that underwent
excision
of renal carcinomas
and we actually worked up the
methodology
to achieve more than 70 success
actually right now we're operating about
95
success so that's actually a really
reassuring outcome for us to be able to
develop
a patient-derived tumor platform
i'm not going to go through everything
we've done but we've actually looked at
parameters such as enzymatic
disaggregation
composition of media the condition of
oxygens
and we also settled on the
methodological step
of isolating the cells expanding them in
2d
and then creating 3d tumors
the images below is just a snapshot from
flow cytometry
where we were trying to actually
identify the cells
we um isolated from patients
and the top panel just basically shows
ca9 expression which is the biomarker
for renal cancer cells and how the
ca9 expression is increasing
with a worsening grade of the disease
to be able to interrogate
patient-derived tumoroids
with the drug of choice we first
optimized all the parameters
in tumors created from cell lines in
this case
a clear cell renal cell carcinoma cell
line
and the images here show how the cells
behave within the cancer mass
itself the left image shows
control drug-free tumors and the right
images
shows how the cancer cells were
distressed
and reduced in numbers after possopony
administration the measurable parameters
were
included in this particular study
were first of all cell viability as you
can see
on the graph to the left top left and
particularly cell viability
across the range of the ic50
concentrations that are used in patients
so you can see a 50 death
say starting after 10 micromolar
but maximizing at 20 micromolar
concentration
and actually the ic50 in patients is 18
micromolar
so we're using parameters which mimic
the clinical scenario
the bottom graph on the left also shows
what happens in the cell cycle of these
cells
and if you look at the g2 group
you can see that there is a
histogram that shows rise in
cells that enter g2
and that is that 14 micromolar
and that again aligns with the action of
pasopanib as we know it
one more parameter we investigated was
the production of the egf
and the results are shown on the
bottom right graph and with increasing
conv
concentration of possopony there is a
significant reduction in the production
of egf
and we tested this in tumeroids that we
grew
for 10 days and we did this because we
wanted
the cells to assume as much morphology
as would be expected from
a mature solid cancer
so having isolated the cells from
patients
and having maximized and optimized the
way we would test
tumors from from patient-derived cells
in a clinical scenario we decided to
carry out
a feasibility and
acceptability study with a very small
number of patients
so we followed a normal trial summary
where we consented patients obviously
screened them
and then presented them with
acceptability questionnaires
and asked them to donate tissue to carry
out
this work in the laboratory i and the
acceptability questionnaires were quite
interesting because when you think about
it you're asking people whether or not
they would be
happy for us to create a personalized
platform that would determine whether or
not there were drug responders
or nog drug responders and the outcome
of that
would be if the platforms show that
people are not
drug responders then that particular
drug would not
be available to them having said that
i'm not going to go
through the answers to this but most
patients we asked
were theoretically happy with this
scenario
so let me go and concentrate again on
the tissue donation
the tissue donation was from just a very
small number
10 or 11 patients we took this tissue
we isolated cells we created hemorrhoids
we let the tumor rise mature for 10 days
and then we applied drug
and tested the response from these
and these are our results in a summary
slide
so we
i am presenting results from nine
patients there
because uh there were um um
events in the laboratory that in the end
stopped us from being able to create
humanoids from the
from the last patient
the time it took for the cells to
grow was between four days
and 26 days
and when we had enough cells we grew
tumuroids
and let them mature for 10 days and
after that
we treated them with poisoponic for
another five days
and the reason i'm actually talking so
specifically about the times
the time it took for the cells to grow
to make the tumor roots and test them
it's because if a platform like this is
going to be
applicable in the clinic it has to be
within
a certain time window before
patients will have to undergo
an extra surgery or before they are
considered for extra
treatment so we're happy with this
timeline
the test we carried out were viability
tests
cell tied to grow again vgf production
and image analysis and of course we are
interrogating this for the genetic
mutations
to ensure that what we grow is
equivalent
to patient tissues
from that particular slide you can see
that only
two of our samples were
strongly responding to pazopanib
one was a weak responder and the rest of
them
were non-responders the images on the
bottom show again images from the cancer
mass itself
and you can see how the treated tumorous
on the right
has less cells than the
control tumor that didn't receive any
drug
and those outcomes were corroborated
with cell viability measures
and others so we're happy
that this type of work is feasible
obviously to be able to determine
whether or not
tumeroids as we create them in the lab
are equivalent to
tissues from the patient we had to carry
out
genetic profiling i cannot disclose
all the results we have however i will
say that for the patient-derived renal
tumoroids
we created a bespoke panel of genes that
are associated with
a clear cell renal cell carcinoma
and since we haven't um published this i
apologize i cannot share all the
information
however just by from that simple
table you can see that we have
a minimum of two mutations from
the most frequent mutations found in
this cancer type
for each one of these samples and of
course
um one of the genes that we had to
include
is vhl which is a characteristic
mutation for this particular cancer type
and also k ras which is a
downstream effector of the map kinase
cascade
we are currently comparing this
to genetic analysis from the
patient issues and we look forward to
sharing our results with this community
in the future
so i would now like to focus on
um one of our steps that we think is
key to be able to turn tumoroids into
platforms that can be used generally
within a clinical setting a clinical
diagnostic
setting and that particular test i would
like to
concentrate on is how to
maximize automate and
reduce the time it takes to
isolate cells from a donated tissue
currently to isolate cells from a
patient
tissue it takes the whole process takes
about
four hours and for this to be done in a
laboratory on a regular basis
it has to be really less than an hour
so to take that forward we've undertaken
very recently a study
where we're actually disaggregating
tissues from patients with renal cancer
using two methods the first one is the
manual method
we optimized and the second one
is by using an automated tissue
disaggregator equipment
so if i can bring you to your attention
the
bottom row of that schematic
what we do is that we have tissue
donated by pathology
and we use one gram of tissue
for this process to be able to manually
disaggregate cells we take this tissue
we mince it up and it takes about 20
minutes to mince up
one gram of tissue and then we add a
cocktail of enzymes that we've
um we've optimized
for about an hour and then filter
to actually get cells that we can put in
culture
and then grow like i said before
although
um this schematic shows 20 minutes plus
60 minutes actually the whole process
of receiving the tissue recording the
tissue
then doing this and then putting in
culture
takes up to four hours
now the top part of the schematic
shows the process if we use an automated
tissue disaggregator
so we have one gram of tissue we don't
mince
we put the bits of tissue inside a bag
if you like a container where we
actually
also place our enzymes the ones that we
optimized
and then we simply place that container
in the equipment in the tissue
disaggregator
and we desegregate for 10 minutes
and that gives us cells
that we can put in culture so
what we want to finish is this in this
study
is a robust comparison between
both methods using a minimum
of 10 tissues
i'm sure like everybody understands
because of their pandemic situation
access to laboratories and actually
access to tissues
has been reduced however
we have managed to go back in the lab
and
access tissues from patients undergoing
surgery
and i'm just going to show you very
simply
the results from our first two samples
and if you look at the first sample
the manual method vessels that
disaggregate our method
um are compared in terms of the total
concentration of
cells we received from both method
methods and life and death cells
so for the first sample the
cells we received from the very simple
disaggregation method
was four and a half million cells
which is much larger than those who
receive from the manual method which is
2.4 million
cells again
in terms of viability live cells versus
stem cells
we're getting a viability of 75 percent
with the automated disaggregation method
versus 69
with the manual method so those are
equivalent
if i can go on to sample two
those same parameters seem to be
equivalent
so the concentrations of cells derived
by the two methods are very similar
and the viability of those cells
is again very similar so
just as a snapshot just from two samples
it looks like the disaggregator which
only takes 10 minutes
yields equal or more cell numbers
at this time and we are delighted and
relieved that the viability is actually
equivalent or better
however this is early days but this is
encouraging results
and this slide just shows the images of
these cells
and i apologize these are rather boring
images in
black and white and gray scale but what
they
demonstrate is the cells
in culture from the manual
disaggregation method
and the cells in culture from the
automated disaggregator method
and for both sample 1 and sample 2
you can see that the cells are alive
they're viable
they're reaching confluence and at least
for sample one
it appears that there are more cells
from the automated
disaggregator method than the manual
these cells are still currently in
culture
and they've almost reached confluence so
we're very much looking forward to being
able to
create tumors out of this
and test drugs
not only are we looking forward to
creating tumoroids
from these patient-derived cells but
also we're taking forward
genetic investigations
to identify again the mutations that are
linked
to each patient but this will be
carried out in the future
so what i've done is just give a
whistleblower presentation
of developing the tumult model
optimizing a method where we can access
patient-derived cells from
patients that underwent surgery for
kidney cancer
to include into the tumoroids and i
focused a little bit
on automating one of the key steps
in this process which is the isolation
of cells
from tissues from the patients
because as i said at the beginning our
vision is to be able to present this
as a robust platform
that can be used widely
to determine responders and
non-responders from cancer
patients what are we doing next
obviously we're doing whole genome
analysis of cells
that we've grown in 2d cells
how they're going to be present in the
3d tumeroids
versus the original cancer tissues
and we are in the process of
constructing tumors to determine
drug response
i'm gonna stop there but i would like
first of all to
thank all my collaborators from the
tumorous group that are focusing on this
particular
study the optimized automated
disaggregation of cells
so amber chema who's the convex inventor
of tumor it's with me
andy fieber who's a molecular biologist
maxine tran the consultant surgeon
and an invaluable service
in the department that provides a robust
pathway
for collecting these tissues called tap
b
tissue access for patient benefit
so craig mcpherson and i mean amir
gander from that team
and this work and these images would not
have been
possible without our excellent post-doc
tagabe and our phd student kelly
and i would like to thank sativa for
their support
and finish with an image and list
of the more extended team tumoroid
from ucl collaborators from across the
uk
and the world and the postdocs and phds
without whom this work would not have
been presented today
i would like to acknowledge all the hard
work and their excellent outcomes
thank you very much paredes from
across the uk and the world
and the post docs and phds without
because you're playing the video perfect
thank you so much
and welcome to the q and a portion of
this webinar
welcome back marlina it looks like we
have some great questions
coming in and i want to encourage our
audience and members
to go ahead and submit any questions
that they have
an interest in asking at this time our
first question
coming in is how do you see the solid
tissue
isolation process evolving
well thank you very much um
i think that isolating tissue
and having a really robust automated way
of doing it
of processing tissue into cells and
other components
is key for all work
that uses human material and
um i'm delighted that there are products
equipment now coming online that
actually
um are gonna offer this there is no way
we're gonna be able to translate any of
this pre
clinical work into clinical platform
unless we actually manage to do this so
there's more and more
sophistication in the equipment and
there's more flexibility on the
equipment
but we need to have this in all
laboratories that
are dealing with human tissues we need
to have a really good equipment to do
this
thank you so much and marilyna in what
ways
will your tumeroids be used to inform
cancer research and diagnostics in the
future
so this is very much my vision this is
very much
our vision and
we know that we are not
actually delivering the best possible
adjuvant treatment to patients with
cancer
and we need to have platforms that
really give us
real answers and
the way we're taking tumerics forward is
that we have designed
larger trials where we actually
manufacture tumeroids and interrogate
them for drug response or
non-response and we
look back at the patients
and their treatment to be able to
identify whether or not the tumorous
responses
correspond to the patient responses
and we need about something like 180
patients to get a good answer
so if we have con concordance between
the patient responses and the tumor
responses to the same drug then that
gives
a really really good um answer on how
we're gonna take tumerics forward but we
really want to develop this
into a platform that's going to be
widely used and it's going to give real
answers for specific patients
and thank you so much and again i want
to thank our audience members for these
great questions coming in
what have been the main challenges
encountered with the tumeric study to
date
okay so the greatest challenge
the greatest challenge has been to
optimize the isolation
and growth of patient-derived
cells when we embarked on this we had a
five-year program and we thought it
would not be
that difficult to isolate cells from
patients
and it's been the huge the the most huge
stumbling block it really took us over
two years
just to optimize cell isolation
from patients with kidney cancers and
we started with four different cancer
types
we wanted to try it out for prostate
cancer
for kidney cancer for bowel cancer
and for lung cancer so
we took forward kidney cancers because
we started getting really good results
from the
original isolations i think that's a
that's a huge step i think that
for different cancer types
different initial pros processing can
take place for example
if somebody wants to make tumerics with
colorectal cancer
it might be that the best methodology to
follow
would be to create organoids from
colorectal cancer
and then incorporate them into humanoids
but so each cancer type is going to have
a different methodological optimized
methodology for that particular step
so i think that's been the greatest the
greatest challenge
thank you so much we have time for a
couple more questions
how does your approach compare with the
genetic profile approach to determining
uh appropriate drugs from each patient
thank you that's a great question um
this is not competing technology
genetic profiles or biomarker profiles
are incredibly useful for example we
know that
take breast cancer the expression of the
receptor
her2 identified
a subgroup of patients that would
benefit
from the antibody
herceptin which is directed against
her too so having a profile
molecular or genetic that identifies
those particular biomarkers
or upgraded genes it's incredibly useful
it gives you like the first filter
for for stratifying treatment
but if i can follow up with a herceptine
argument
although patients that express her to
are treated with herceptin the patients
that benefit
from that are less than 50 percent
so there are other factors that
determine
the response to the drug so it could be
genetic it could be epigenetic
it could be environmental so by creating
an organoid or a tumoroid
you actually create the
3d or you try to mimic the 3d
positioning of cells
and you give them an environment where
they can have
cues or messages coming to them
that are extra to
a genetic or molecular profile so by
having
a tumorous platform then
you're gonna you might get different
answers
in terms of drug responses to what you
would get
by profiling the tissues it could be
that in different cancer types
there should be an approach where two
such methodologies are combined you can
have both
genetic profiling and an organoid
or a tumorous platform giving answers
and the only way we're going to figure
this out
for each specific cancer type is to take
forward studies where we compare
these different approaches for the same
patient
and at the same time we try and see
compared to what happens when the
patient receives that particular
treatment by taking
such studies forward i think we can
isolate and identify
what's the best approach to use
to determine personalized responses for
different cancer types
thank you very much we have time for one
more question
do you think the passage of the cells
through 2d
ex expansion will change the phenotype
before going back into 3d interesting
yes but yeah that's a really really good
question and i can see
it's grand i know graham cameron hello
grant
uh wonderful to so to sort of talk
through this platform
um yes that's an excellent question
um possibly yes
because to the expansion if you
each step
in the whole methodology of isolation
and growth
has the opportunity to change the cells
so taking the cells out from the tissue
one assault putting them into 2d where
they actually grow
on a very very hard plastic and not
in the normal sort of orientation that
they have in the body
and then going into 3d again
you put them into 3d but that's not
necessarily the same 3d as the
patient 3d it tries to mimic the patient
3d
but it doesn't have all the
characteristics so
each one of those steps has the
opportunity for cells to change
in terms of phenotype and also the
opportunities there
for subpopulations of cells to overtake
the others so the short answer is yes
however the only way we're going to
actually identify what's happening
is to look at the original tissue and
the cells have been isolated
at the cells at the end of the 2d
expansion
and at the cells that are growing within
3d
and that's the only way that we can
actually
determine either have been phenotypic
shifts and that is what we're trying to
do
right now with the study where we're
comparing the
disaggregation using the manual method
versus
the disaggregation using the automated
method because that is an absolute key
question thank you
marilyna hello easy dude thank you so
much for this presentation today
was fabulous would you like to provide
the audience with
a closing remark before we go
wow well i haven't prepared a closing
remark i'm
really really honored and i'm grateful
to be given the opportunity to present
this work
and um i would like to say that
the developments in this field
are very very exciting and i think
whether or not it's this methodology or
other methodologies
that there's going to be some real
breakthroughs in the next
five to ten years on how to develop
personalized
personalized cancer treatment thank you
very much
marilyn i thank you again for your time
today and i want to thank our audience
members for their questions questions
that were not
presented today in the q a but were
submitted
will be addressed via email thanks again
marlena
and this presentation will be available
for on the van
viewing for 12 months please remember to
share it with your colleagues who may be
interested in today's
topic and don't miss out on the other
presentations
on our agenda visit the agenda tab in
the auditorium for a full listing
thanks again for your participation
until next time
stay safe and stay healthy take care
bye